it's a very very difficult business to
break into hearing know that many times
really it builds you a skin that puts
you ready to take on anything in the
world something doesn't work out with
this acting thing I don't know what
don't listen to you anymore
need motivation watch the top 10 with
believe nation
he's rami malek
and here's my take on his top ten roses
success enjoy
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one build tough skin Oh some of the best
rolls I've ever played have just been in
5-minute auditions that no one's ever
seen the amount of times I've gotten in
you know into my car on the train after
an audition and just like wanted to
scream or screamed or even cried at
times I was just like but it's good I
mean hearing know that many times really
it builds you a skin that puts you ready
to take on anything in the world
rule number two master your craft I met
choreographers early on and I said oh no
I'm not gonna be choreographed nothing
he did was a five six seven eight
everything he went out there he didn't
know what was gonna happen from second
to second and you feel moments where his
adrenaline is just kicking in I needed
to have that happen for me take after
take after take so it was about just
having him live organically and within
me and I had the help of Paulie Bennett
a movement teacher who just helped me
develop that so that anytime anyplace I
could jump into my version of Freddy
rule number three being committed I'm
already in debt from school from
studying theatre there's no way as much
as I would love to learn more about this
I do want to kind of give it a go too
and I went to in New York and I lived
with a couple friends in a one-bedroom
apartment that was not fun and then one
day I went back to Los Angeles to visit
family and my theater director Devon's
really said I want you to meet a casting
director was malli Finn and she's she's
passed on but she was incredible and she
looked at me and she said you know just
stay here for a while you know Los
Angeles he grew up here give it a go I
think something could happen for you it
was like yeah right okay why not okay
move everything back home and ended up
moving back in with your parents sadly
did save a little money she said listen
get your headshot and resume and send it
to every agent you can and go into every
every film school and just leave a box
of them everywhere well I went and did
everything she said I sent them to every
every agent every school and every
casting agent as well and one day I got
a call after doing this for quite some
time and not hearing how long did it
take to her back Oh a long time like a
year a couple years at least a year yeah
before I even got one phone call out of
it do you have a day job during this
time oh yeah what's the worst day job
you had I had some pretty crazy day jobs
but one was I was working as a busboy
for a long time and I think it's called
the Rockwell now where they do all those
musicals
[Music]
you know what I'm talking about and I
remember one day my boss came up to me
and you know I've just been I've been
working my ass off there and he looked
at my my cup of espresso that I made for
someone and he said that is an inferior
macchiato something doesn't work out
with this acting thing I don't know
listen to you anymore
rule number four do your own thing
Tommy William in math man I'm a medic
ahead hour away in Upper Egypt cone
machine Hannah I know whom you heard
Yahoo totally as Itzhak toward where a
lawyer I got kinda where that was hard
because you know MoMA sylla's is not
considered the greatest career to go
into from that standpoint best you know
family gets it it's a different story
it's it's really a special career to be
a part of and you know now that I've
achieved some success everybody seems
very happy with that but it's difficult
it's it's it's a very very difficult
business to break into and I'm very
fortunate that I've been able to just
I've just kept going also if you want to
learn how to have confidence check out
my free to 54 confidence series the link
is in the description below my call time
is at 7 then you back your clock up for
hours and then that's when I get up I
was excited about taking a shot the fact
that it was so strange
failed big
that's right feel big you only live once
so do what you feel passionate about
passionate about rule number five be
bold you've jumped into a giant
franchise called Night at the Museum
which is I think are under five hundred
and forty million dollars worldwide and
all the sequels which is an amazing
experience tell me what it was like to
be on that set we had Robin Williams
Mickey Rooney Dick Van Dyke Shawn Levy
directing I mean Ben Stiller obviously
starring that that was a huge
opportunity how did that feel
that was unreal yeah we're the I could
not believe I got that job I was over
the moon I mean doing my film a major
motion picture a huge film how did you
get that role specifically had someone
seen you in one of the - no you know I
think that had a lot to do with playing
a pharaoh and me being Egyptian okay and
I'm wearing this big puffy jacket as a
Pharaoh and these big kind of snow boots
that have rainbows on them and I start
improving with Ben Stiller for the first
he starts throwing lines at me and going
off-book and then I'd start going
off-book
I had really prepared myself so because
I knew that might happen yeah so I
thought of some stuff to come up with
and I went home that night and I saw all
those kids from New York that I went to
college with took them out for drinks at
a bar and I still had eyeliner on I
could not get the eye this Kohl eyeliner
very intense and I just couldn't believe
it
get to buy my friends round of drinks
and for the first time and just improv
with Ben Stiller and Robin Williams I
mean I was over the moon I go back to LA
we're about to shoot in Vancouver and I
see that my date to shoot keeps getting
pushed and I thought man what's going on
something's going on and I got a call
from Kim door my agent and she said do
you know there's if there's a reason why
they have another breakdown out for the
character of ahkmenrah I said what I
know this makes so much sense well it
turns out that while I was doing this
film I came up with this idea that
Aquaman raw was he was trapped in you
know a sarcophagus at Cambridge
University as it said in the script
right so he become kind of like this
Cambridge dandy right so maybe I had
taken it a little too far with the blue
puffer jacket and the snow boots and the
eyeliner that I couldn't get off for
days I think the movie studio Fox yeah
inevitably would do her game in Rhapsody
so this all has a great
but they were a little concerned about
my depiction of the Egyptian fare so
fortunately Shaun goes come on up
I'm God we're gonna do a makeup test and
you got to give me a different read on
this character even though he'd already
saw the exterior yeah they were ready to
move on oh boy my first job I was like I
was like this business is tough enough
right oh come on give me a break but
fortunately I had I think Stiller had
some faith in me and Sean had some faith
in me and they pushed and fortunately I
made my way back in there clawed my ass
back in there so how much did you learn
from that about there's a point to which
maybe over-interpreting you know the
script or maybe bringing too much of
yourself to it or did it just not gonna
say that was my five I looking back on
it I think I really enjoyed what I was
doing I might have watched Pirates of
the Caribbean a few - okay you got one
shot at this right I'm gonna be bold
rule number six seize every opportunity
what was the very first thing you
auditioned for that's pertinent records
oh the first thing I auditioned for I
actually I got a call from a casting
director she asked to speak to the agent
representing rami malek and I said
speaking and she said well what's your
name I said this is Rami and she kind of
laughed and she said why are you sag I
said no I think I've made the giraffe
already the way and she started laughing
and laughing and she said all right call
me when you're you have an agent and
you're sit properly sag oh you're
already laughing give me a shot who's
three lines in the Gilmore Girls that's
your answer
Wow I got the part no I got the part the
part in your first-ever audition was
also playing your agent I just left your
agent had a lot to live up to after that
as well you're like wonderful one yes
exactly
rule number seven do different things
I've always have been disgruntled for a
certain time about all the other roles
and in Hollywood going you know for
Middle Eastern people were the rules of
happy the terrorists and you know it's
sad it's sad to see people going out for
just this role to play the villain and I
always wanted to do something else I
wanted I wanted to just do a variety of
roles and and show place some very
complicated characters and show the you
know so show range I wanted to look back
it at my career and be proud of all the
different things I got to do rule number
eight
find your true path I lived in the
valley and I swear to you you probably
won't believe this but I didn't even
know that this side of Los Angeles
existed until I was about 16 or 17 and
that sounds crazy but that's how
sheltered I was I mean I just went went
to school and hung out with my friends
and knew that Hollywood was somewhere
around but I didn't realize were your
parents sheltering you from Hollywood or
they wanted you to be more polite
academic yeah I think was focused on
academics I'm a first-generation
American so they came from Cairo and
they were just seeking a better life and
you know I think they thought we're
paying for you to go to school here
you're gonna do things that help you
excel and that was to be in politics or
law or a doctor and so I took the bake
class in high school and that didn't
really work out for me but I had I had a
great substitute teacher that came in
one day and he was kind of a comedian
his name was Lester Barry and he could
recognize hey you're not you're not
really cut out for this but you can do
this thing called the dramatic or
humorous interpretation and I said
what's that and said we just look at a
play and you can basically have it in
front of you and you act it out and he
gave me this one-man show is called zoom
in and the sign by Charles Fuller and I
remember taking it home and just I just
read through it as fast as I could and
something something happened and I
remember looking at it in the first
lunges
my name is zoom and Z double o MA and
I'm from the bottom and I just heard
myself it and on the 13 come up with
this new character that someone else had
written that I just hadn't created in my
head
and I felt I felt powerful in our way
and I chose it to him about a week later
and he looked at me and I think he had
this look of oh oh that's that's not bad
rule number nine take risks from the
perspective of this generation a new
generation Millennials will will see
Queen possibly for the first time and
get to know Freddy for the first time so
we want it to be as intimate as we could
with his life and showing an aspect of
who this person was behind closed doors
how a young man from humble beginnings
can come to view one of the greatest
rock stars the world has ever known and
be a part of one of the greatest rock
bands the world has ever known it's an
opportunity of a lifetime and yes it
chances are it could go very very wrong
but you know you can't live life without
taking a few risks and I like a
challenge I guess this is probably the
biggest one I'll ever take in my life
and I have fingers crossed if it works
and rule number ten the last one before
a very special bonus clip is chase your
dreams
I think about
I think about what it would have been
like to tell little Bubba rami that one
day this might happen to him and I think
his curly-haired little mind would be
blown that kid was he was struggling
with his identity trying to figure
himself out and I think to anyone
struggling with theirs and trying to
discover their voice listen we made a
film about a gay man an immigrant who
lived his life just unapologetically
himself and the fact that I'm
celebrating him and this story with you
tonight is his proof that we're longing
for for stories like this I am the son
of immigrants from Egypt I'm a first
generation American and
of my story is being written right now
I've got a really special bonus clip on
how to tell great stories that I think
you're gonna enjoy but before that it's
time for the three point landing
questions let's go from just watching
the video to taking action here we go
question number one where do you need to
be bold and chase your dreams number two
where do we need to toughen your skin
and number three what risk are you gonna
take today I did this audition with with
Joe mazzello and it was a really dark
scene where my character is actually
throwing some pebbles into this
sawed-off head of a Japanese enemy who's
been he's been sitting there dead for a
while and it was a very very intense
scene and they remember the casting
assistant was getting really in our
faces with the camcorder moving I mean
more than I'd ever seen a casting
assistant move and and older than I'd
ever seen a casting mister and they
realized that's no ordinary casting
assistant that Steven Spielberg
and don't stop talking say your lines
and in that moment I remember you're
either gonna either all gonna go to or
something really great is done let's
pick the right move here and fortunately
I did I just I gathered all my
confidence and I said let's give Steven
the best show you could get them right
now and I don't know if that happened
but I haven't walked out of there yeah
and I got the job and I could not
believe in
if you want to learn how to make it as
an actor go check out the video right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
everybody told me not to be an actor to
this day I say that to people who come
up to me and say I'm thinking of going
into acting what do you think I say
absolutely not it's a terrible idea
don't do it